so now the US was faced with the
opposite problem how do we make use of
all this corn the government knew that
people just couldn't keep eating more
and more corn on the cob so they had to
come up with new ways to integrate corn
into society they needed to diversify
their corn portfolio corn is milled by
either a wet or dry process so it's
transformed into syrups and starches
that also end up as ingredients in other
processed foods people eat every day and
because corn was subsidized by the
government it incentivized companies to
come up with creative ways to turn the
super cheap crop into expensive high
margin products and so corn oil was
invented cornstarch was invented
cornmeal corn flour corn cereal and
other stuff like ethanol and Plastics
all these things came into being because
of these government subsidies